[Musique]
couchez vous tous sur le sol regorge de
bons moments les suspects sont armés et
ont pris des otages et à toutes les
unités
n'intervenez pas
vous regardez comment vous comptez
sortie
on n'a pas affaire à des voleurs
ordinaire les vaincus
la réserve fédérale la seule banque à
avoir jamais été braqué c'est pour ça
qu'on va faire
ce ne sont pas de simples braqueurs la
nationale au niveau de banque la banque
laguna sont coincés gars on résout
toutes ces affaires c'est eux qu'il faut
qu'on chante
ils sont accros bagages d'audard il leur
faudra leur 12e puis 100 milliards de
dollars l'attend examen minutieux et
vient
ils ont réussi à s'infiltrer
il voit grand
tu sais ce que ça veut dire que je fais
partie d'un gang sauf que nous on a des
plaques
ce qui veut dire aussi que t'es foutu
vendredi démerde toi pour qu'il soit au
courant
je préfère te prévenir faut mettre ton
gilet au moindre mouvement tu y es tu
crois qu'on est du genre à tasser les
bracelets
non on va vous butez
c'est pas fou les méchants
c'est nous